DAVID LANG:A few years ago, I
had this big epiphany.
How do we shift
from just something
we're building together
to all of these ways that we
could be exploring together?
We're building the largest
ocean observation network
in the world and we're
doing it with other people.
It's powered by citizens.
So I'm gonna start my
story four years ago.
I met this amazing person
named Eric Stackpole
and he told me this
wonderful story about
this underwater cave that was
filled with gold supposedly.
And he told this whole story
of treasure hunters who
had tried to find it,
and then he showed me this
little underwater robot
that he was trying
to build to explore.
It's called an ROV, a
remotely operated vehicle,
and how it works is it goes
down underneath the surface.
It's got a camera, it sends
live video up a thin tether
to the operator on the
surface who can see
what it's seeing and drive it.
I was captivated
by Eric's story.
We didn't have any money to buy
one of these ROVs ourselves,
and unfortunately,
we also didn't know
how to build one ourselves.
We had an early prototype,
but it didn't work.
So we did what anybody
would do in our position,
we asked the internet for help.
( laughter )
We created a website
called OpenROV.com
and we started asking
people to critique
our designs and
help us improve it.
At first, it was just me
and Eric asking questions
to each other about buoyancy
and basic engineering,
and slowly, people began to add
feedback and give us advice.
I think they just
took pity on us,
but eventually, we
got to the point
where the robot was good
enough to take to the caves,
so we got our friends together,
we mounted a little expedition,
and we sent the robot
into the back of the cave
and it went down, down.
We found millions
of dollars of gold.
( laughter )
Actually, we didn't.
We didn't find anything,
but we learned a lot,
and that was the
important thing.
And one of the important
things we learned
was that this low cost
underwater robot kit
was something that
other people wanted.
And so, we decided to
put it on Kickstarter,
and we raised $100,000.
This was back in
2012 when that was
a lot of money on Kickstarter,
and it was certainly
more than we expected,
and it caused us
to really quickly
outgrow our garage operation.
I remember the day when
the boxes showed up
and I was thinking, oh, my gosh.
But we got them together
and we got them shipped out,
and over the past three years,
we've shipped thousands
of these things
to every corner of the globe.
They've gone to the bottom
of the Earth in Antarctica.
They've gone to the
top of the Earth.
I got this photo last
week from an explorer
who was studying glacial
lakes in the Himalayas.
These are schools in Oakland.
These are communities
in Papua New Guinea.
We have people who
are discovering
glass sponge reefs
in British Columbia.
We have people who are
creating 3D visualizations
of habitat for
Caribbean monk seals.
I mean, the community just
continues to surprise us.
This was from last week.
We were up at Lake Tahoe.
We found a shipwreck
at 120 meters
and we were
streaming it all live
to Facebook and
Ustream and Twitch TV.
It was pretty exciting
moment for us last week.
Our latest design
is the Trident.
So, we took all the
things that we've learned
over the past three
years and we put that
into a new design
for underwater robots
that we think is a
evolutionary step forward
for low cost underwater drones.
This thing is fast, it
flies like a fighter jet,
but it's also
super maneuverable,
and still costs less than $1500.
So other people
wanted this, too,
and so we raised $810,000
for this on Kickstarter
last October and we're
preparing to ship it in the fall
of this year, so we're
really excited about that.
I think this is pretty amazing.
In just a few years, two
guys in a garage have
turned into a global
community of ocean explorers.
We're building the largest
ocean observation network
in the world, and we're
doing it with other people.
It's powered by citizens.
This is Laura James.
She was one of the
first people to notice
that sea stars were dying
around the Puget Sound
and she notified scientists
and they confirmed
that it was part of
this widespread die off
that was going on
around the Pacific coast
called sea star
wasting syndrome.
They didn't know
what was causing it,
and Laura was not
content with that answer,
so she started a
citizen science project
to get people to notice
and contribute data.
That data was then part
of Pete Raimondi's work
at UC Santa Cruz, and they
did this amazing PBS story
about Laura and her
citizen science project
and all the people
that are contributing,
and a Congressman saw that
and decided to introduce
the Emergency
Marine Disease Act,
and so there's this bill
in Congress right now.
You can call and
help push it along,
but I love this story
because this is it.
You know, this isn't
just a headline
that sea stars are dying.
This is people who
are getting involved.
This is congresspeople
who are taking notice
and action is happening.
Laura and her team
are still out there.
Now they're monitoring
storm water runoff
to see if that's the problem.
They're looking at urchins to
see if the virus is spreading.
It's the scientific method,
actually becomes the message.
There's this whole
architecture for participation.
That's a big deal.
So I don't wanna
go into the details
of what's going on in Flint.
It's an ongoing disaster and
all of you know about it.
But I do wanna point
out that that, too,
was a citizen science project.
Professor Mark Edwards
at Virginia Tech
was sick of the
institutional failure
so he gave out 300 kits
to the community and said,
"You guys need to start testing
your water and take action."
And they did.
There's a fantastic
piece in Wired.
My favorite paragraph
is towards the end
it said, "This kind
of citizen-powered,
"apocalypse-averting
science is spreading."
And he went on to
list a whole host
of citizen science projects
that were doing similar work.
At the end of that paragraph,
I love this line,
I'm gonna read it.
"Researchers are learning
that there's a difference
"between publishing
results and actually,
"you know, getting them."
( laughter )
( applause )
And so that's where we are.
That's what's going on.
The tools are getting
really good, really fast.
All of the micro-controllers
and sensors and cameras
and GPS are now building
blocks that makers can use
and all of these maker
spaces are popping up
all over the world, in
classrooms, in museums,
in libraries, and
just in neighborhoods.
It's profound, and
people have access
to powerful digital
fabrication tools
like laser cutters
and 3D printers.
It would've been
impossible for Eric
to do what we did
just five years ago.
I mean, we're really at
the very beginning of this.
This is our same garage; this
is our roommates at the time,
and they had this idea to
create low cost satellites
using these same components,
and so they prototyped
this satellite in the
garage, and they have since
started a company, raised
hundreds of millions of dollars,
and launched a constellation
of hundreds of satellites
that are now getting an image
of every location
on Earth every day.
It's a big company and
they're doing important work.
This is an illegal gold
mining operation in Peru
that they found
encroaching on this river.
It's really extraordinary.
I mean, this used to be
the stuff of nation states,
and now it's our roommates
starting this in the garage.
( laughter )
It's extraordinary.
This is not just a Silicon
Valley story either.
These are DIY drones being used
in Indonesia for conservation.
Fifty-cent microscopes,
tens of thousands
of people are exploring
the microcosmos.
Creating DIY Geiger
counters to monitor
the radiation after Fukushima.
There's all sorts of low-
cost, DIY bio equipment
that are being used
to power garage labs
and community bio
labs across the world.
The list goes on and on.
We need everyone to see
themselves as explorers.
We need everybody to
recognize that they have
the agency to be
curious, to ask questions
because I promise you,
when you give people
the tools to ask questions,
they will surprise you
with what they ask and
with what they discover.
Thank you.
( applause )